people are trying to get the train they
have a passport control and they come to
the
poor polish border
the train comes to three cities
paramschel helm and rubasho that's it
they are waiting for his line
and it line lasts i think maximum three
hours that's it well let's go down and
see that dennis thank you very much
indeed down here it's going to get very
dark actually
many of the people here have obviously
seen some terrible things they're
extremely tired as well
some of them have come by train uh here
some of them have taken buses some
private cars but it's been a very
difficult journey many of them are very
angry actually at what they've seen as
well which is a bombardment of their
homes and many have been driven because
they're so desperate not to leave
because it's got so bad that's why as i
said it's going to get very dark people
held down here for as we heard three or
four hours waiting as you can see
cueing they try to keep it as controlled
as they possibly can we'll just go
through to the next part
but many of them as you can see are
women and young children
pets there as well i see
and as you can see they hold them back
in barriers to try and make this as
controlled and calm a process as
possible but
lots of young children waiting for a
very long time to get here the
volunteers try to give them food and any
medicine that they need
but the
tunnels as you can see under these
platforms go on and on and then the
station concourse itself is also full of
people and outside there some of them as
i said arriving by
bus and private transport there are some
tents there with food
trying to provide some people with some
sustenance to make the onward journey
but it is so incredibly uncertain for
them many people
don't necessarily know where they're
going and where they will end up and
really are desperately sad to leave
ukraine